为了要降低终端设备的成本
因此使用整合的射频机体电路
由于低轨道卫星的移动速度非常快
因此地面的接收设备必须使用向位阵列天线
而低轨道卫星所使用的地面接收设备里面
射频机体电路非常重要的元件就是
各位曲博科技教师的观众朋友大家好
我是曲博
大家都知道低轨道卫星是最近非常热门的话题
而低轨道卫星里面呢
终端设备所使用的射频机体电路
大家可能比较陌生
今天我们就来跟大家谈谈在卫星通讯里面
需要使用到的上传下载变频器
UDC到底是什么元件
在今天的影片开始之前
我们要先来聊一下人工智慧的发展趋势
现在整个产业都在谈人工智慧
如何重新定义未来
当人工智慧结合5G
物联网以及机器学习
不只是云端更会走向边缘
推动智慧家庭无人机智慧城市等等
这些应用可以快速落地
2025 EEE Intelligent Techcom
前瞻技术大会
将会在10月1日和10月2日
在大巨蛋旁边的台北文创六楼举办
今年的主题是What's next
未来关键技术发展
这次的论坛特别聚焦在人工智慧的边缘运算
智慧生活机器人和无人机
卫星以及下世代通讯
还有大家最关注的小晶片封装
以及细光子和高速互联技术
现场邀请到Microsoft ARM
还有爱卡拉
ADI NVIDIA 联发科
以及国家太空中心
和台湾无人机协会等重量级的演讲者
还有国际大厂来展示最新的技术
我也会亲自到现场分享
谈谈深层市人工智慧
如何翻转产业新趋势
这是一场整合产业生态
交流前瞻思维的盛会
诚挚的邀请大家
10月1号和10月2号来台北文创一起探索未来科技的发展蓝图
接下来我们就开始今天的节目
所以我们今天的题目是来自太空的网细网路
低轨道卫星LEO的射频机体电路RFIC发展趋势
首先我们跟大家谈谈低轨道卫星的连接通向成功之路
再来谈谈低轨道卫星的特性和标准
以及低轨道卫星系统如何工作
最后我们和大家谈谈用户终端的上传下载变频器UDC的发展趋势
以及更高性能的终端上传下载
变频器有哪些特性
最后我们和大家谈谈使用电子可控天线
来降低用户终端的成本
我们今天的这套来源是亚德诺半导体
ADI的市场行销与业务发展总监
Dano McAlessy发表在电子工程专辑
EETIMES的文章
题目是来自太空的网际网路
LEO卫星的RFIC进展
首先呢这个文章就谈到
低轨道卫星的网际网路连接
是一个令人期待的新领域
如今大多数政府和网际网路供应商
都已经在盘算参加这一场太空竞赛
随着全球的互联程度不断提高
地轨道卫星将进一步增强
第三代合作伙伴计划3GPP
也就是制定第三代行动电话
和第四代第五代行动电话的组织
所制定的标准
从太空到农村地区的连接能力
进而在5G当中发挥重要的效用
这篇文章将会介绍推动低轨道卫星部署的主要市场趋势
并且讨论低轨道卫星系统的基本运行情况
以及展示半导体的射频机体电路技术取得相关的进展
这些进展正在推动下一代的KA和KU频段
用户中端和地面中端相关的设备
大家现在看到的这个就是无线通讯所使用的电磁波频谱
越左边频率越低
越右边频率越高
包括L-band S-band C-band X-band K-band K-band K-band K-band V-band和W-band
频率越低的电磁波
它的资料传输率越低天线的尺寸越大
频宽越窄受到雨水影响越小
而频率越高的电磁波
它的资料传输率越高天线的尺寸越小
频宽越宽受到雨水的影响越大
接下来我们跟大家谈谈低轨道卫星连接通向成功之路
卫星通讯STATCOM是一种成熟的语音影像和数据传输方式
在所有主要轨道包含地球的同步轨道GEO和中轨道MEO
还有低轨道LEO卫星上面都广泛的使用
卫星通讯被认为是传输卫星定位GPS导航讯号
天气概括电视广播语音数据的有效手段
同时也用来成像和科学应用
并且可以提供高速网际网路连接的新一波计划
已经围绕在低轨道卫星展开
将会为下一代网际网路通讯提供低延迟高容量的频宽连接
所谓的同步轨道卫星GEO距离地球表面最远
只需要三颗卫星就可以覆盖整个地球表面
而中轨道卫星MEO距离地球表面比较近
大约需要30颗卫星才能覆盖整个地球表面
而低轨道卫星LEO距离地球表面最近
大约需要1万颗卫星才能够覆盖整个地球表面
所以同步轨道卫星GEO距离地球表面35786公里
它是和地球同步运转的卫星
所以会永远固定在地面上空的某一个位置
传送讯号的距离比较远
延迟的时间大约250毫秒
由于高度够高
只需要三颗卫星就可以覆盖大部分的区域
而中轨道卫星MEO距离地球表面2000公里
到35786公里时间的轨道
它的延迟时间大约是100毫秒
目前主要是导航卫星在使用
大约需要20颗到30颗卫星
才能覆盖大部分的地区
而低轨道卫星LEO
距离地球表面2000公里以下的轨道
延迟时间大约20毫秒
目前大多是观测卫星
量测卫星通讯卫星在使用
距离地球表面2000公里
需要大约5000颗卫星
距离地球表面500公里
大约需要1万颗卫星
才能够覆盖大部分的地区
SpaceX公司的星链计划
它的卫星高度
大约是400公里
因此需要大约12000颗卫星
接下来我们跟大家谈谈
地轨道卫星的特性和标准
地轨道卫星大约每两个小时
绕行地球一圈
换算出来的时速大约是27000公里
相当于音速的22倍
从地平线的一端出现
到另一端消失大约只有10分钟
所以手机通讯使用的地面基地台
是基地台不动手机动
手机移动的时候
必须更换基地台来维持通讯
这个我们称为换手hand off或hand over
但是地轨道卫星是手机不动基地台动
所谓的通讯卫星就是把基地台放在外太空
而且基地台在外太空
它移动的速度是音速的22倍
手机大约每10分钟就要换一个基地台来维持通讯
在部署5G行动通讯网路方面地轨道卫星发挥重要的作用卫星网路越来越多参与到第三代合作伙伴计划3GPP的标准当中
而在未来网路中预期的作用
早就在研发当中
2017年3GPP标准启动相关的活动
来了解卫星通讯网路
在5G连接中的可行性
透过3GPP标准的第15
16 17和18版的白皮书
已经有许多活动
是可以支援卫星网络的整合
而低轨道卫星可以为服务欠缺的地区
提供大范围的覆盖
也就是没有地面基地台的地区
特别是面积广大的澳洲或者美国偏远地区
这样就可以为行动中的使用者提供连续的服务
可以连接到机器对机器
machine to machine
还有物联网IoT的装置
而且这是一个值得关注
同时具有成本效益的5G升级途径
而下一代的低轨道卫星系统将会在距离地球表面500公里到2000公里的轨道上运行
实现比过去的卫星网络更具有技术优势的解决方案
在如此接近地球表面的高度表示它能够提供更低延迟的连线
这个对于消费类型或者商业的使用场景非常重要
例如网际网络的游戏或者即时的工业控制或者医疗设备通讯非常重要
低轨道卫星的延迟时间大约50毫秒
也就是电磁波讯号
从地面传送到外太空的卫星
再从外太空的卫星传送为地面的延迟时间
下一代的技术将会改善到20毫秒以下
而同步卫星的延迟时间大约700毫秒
显然低轨道卫星的延迟时间缩短很多
而且低轨道卫星的一个关键推动因素
就是因为它轨道比较低
它的辐射剂量要低得多
因此呢在低轨道卫星上的基地台
发射的电磁波功率要比同步轨道卫星低很多
同样的地面终端设备
发射讯号的功率也低很多
这个非常重要
因为这个就表示可以放宽昂贵
而且令人忘之却步的抗辐射测试要求
而这个会产生规模性的经济
现在建造低轨道卫星的成本已经大幅降低
而且呢由于它的电磁波功率比较低
辐射也比较低
这样就代表可以有更广泛的半导体制成
还有更多的元件可以使用
由于轨道比较低
预计部署的卫星数量会多出许多
低轨道卫星的平均使用寿命
会比以前的中轨道卫星或同步卫星更短
通常低轨道卫星的寿命大约5到8年
这些卫星就会脱离轨道
所以需要更换新的卫星
低轨道卫星必须具有成本效益
才能够支撑卫星和替代卫星的发射
换句话说
低成本在低轨道卫星非常的重要
随着低轨道卫星频宽连接业务开始变得强大
这一些趋势就引起了产业监管机构的注意
当我们追溯到1990年代
这一种网际网络业务是很多家公司的目标
但是很可惜由于部署成本高而且需求有限
最后已失败告终
意思就是在过去低轨道卫星因为成本很高
而且市场的需求有限
大部分的计划都是失败告终
但是快转到今天
我们看到半导体技术有了长足的进步
能够提供不同以往的性能和整合度
再加上相对于偏远或者服务欠缺的地区
对于高速通讯低延迟的通讯
网际网路连接的需求急速的成长
再加上卫星通讯和5G标准的整合
这个就会使得未来低轨道卫星
处在一个更好的基础之上
要取得成功的可能性就更大
那么这个文章在撰写的时候
预计用户可以实现大约100Mbps的最大上传和下载的资料传输率
未来有可能会提高到150Mbps
这样就可以满足更多用户需要观看影音串流这一类高资料传输率应用的需求
而低轨道卫星面临的一个挑战就是卫星始终不断在移动
也就是我们刚刚说的地面接收设备不动
但是基地台在外太空高速的移动
这些卫星必须完全部署好
才能够提供最低可行的服务
这个就表示初期的支出会很高
因为低轨道卫星
它的轨道比较低
因此数量非常多
但是即便如此
似乎也没有办法阻挡现在的成功
特别像SPEXX Starlink发射低轨道卫星
其实已经非常的成功
而且投资者对低轨道卫星
这种可以覆盖全球的商业前景
非常的看好
接下来我们跟大家介绍
低轨道卫星系统如何工作
低轨道卫星的通讯系统
主要有三个部分组成
第一个部分就是低轨道卫星的本体
也就是把基地台放在低轨道卫星上面
另外有地面接收站
Ground Station和使用者终端User Terminal
当我们在家里面上网的时候
透过天线将讯号传送到卫星
再由卫星传送到附近的地面接收站
最后再由地面接收站
连接到目前的网际网络
另外低轨道卫星的移动速度
每个小时超过25000公里
所以从地平线的一端出现
到地平线的另一端消失
大概只有10分钟
另外目前世界各国的低轨道卫星
都在开发卫星跟卫星之间的
无线通讯
称为卫星间连接相关的技术
早期是使用电磁波来通讯
未来会朝向雷射光通讯的方向发展
所以低轨道卫星最重要的三个设备
第一个是用户终端设备
这些终端设备是用户和卫星之间直接连接的手段
往往成本低
容易设定
而且是在我们的家里面
但是呢也可能是行动终端
譬如说海事卫星通讯
也就是用在船上
或者移动中的卫星通讯
也就是用在飞机上
当然也可能是军用的无线电等等
用户终端通常利用高水准的机体电路
整合来简化布料清单
目标就是降低成本
并且保持精巧的外形尺寸
第二个设备是地面站杂道器
ground station
这些是连接到伺服器
用来连接网际网络的资料中心
所使用的地面连接站
通常是透过光纤来连接网际网络
它会将卫星的讯号连接到地面
并且部署在地球上的固定位置
最后是低轨道卫星本体
卫星群被称为星座
在轨道上绕着地球运转
提供同时连接用户东端设备
和地面占杂道器的网路通讯
而地轨道卫星在太空中移动
通常一颗卫星环绕地球一圈的时间
大概在90分钟到110分钟
也就是接近两个小时
这个时间称为轨道周期
因此连接到卫星的用户端
处于这个卫星的范围内时间很短
大约只有10分钟
最多20分钟
普通用户在正常运行期间
会连接到很多颗卫星经过一定的时间之后系统必须将用户移交给范围内的另外一颗卫星也就是我们刚刚提到当第一颗卫星出现大概10分钟之后消失
必须由第二颗卫星接手
用这个方式
类似行驶中的汽车
使用手机的人
在行动通讯网路中的一个基地台
将用户移交给另外一个基地台一样
这个对于如何控制电磁波的波数
来保持最适合的卫星最佳连接路径
提出严格的要求
另外一个有趣的演变是卫星系统
在超出地面站的范围该如何持续的运行
前面的图展示了一些可能影响通向地面站的网络不利的天气状况
总统上遇到天气不利的情形
卫星会使用弯管技术
也就是卫星必须找到另一条通往地球或者其他物体的连线
譬如飞机的连线将它作为跳板来连接太空中的另外一颗卫星
而这个飞机呢可能正处在地面站的范围之内
另外一项新的技术就是透过卫星间通讯
在外太空使用光学也就是雷射光或者极高频的电磁波
例如V-band或者E-band来连接卫星
意思就是呢当低轨道卫星和地面接收站之间
因为天气的因素没有办法通讯的时候
这个低轨道卫星就可以透过卫星间的通讯
连接另外一个低轨道卫星
再由这一个低轨道卫星来连接地面接收站
这样就可以确保卫星通讯的畅通
而目前的卫星通讯
大部分是使用GIGA赫兹的电磁波
也就是特高频超高频和制高频
另外目前在发展当中的
就是使用红外光镭射来进行卫星间的通讯
可以有更宽的频宽
但是它的绕色特性更差
发射和接收的元件制作更为困难
接下来我们跟大家谈谈用户终端设备的上传下载变频器 UDC 的发展趋势
用户终端对于机体电路的整合提出了很高的要求
那这一篇文章主要是介绍亚德诺 ADI 利用细制程技术的性能和整合能力
来应应这个机体电路的需求
这个解决方案需要非常高的机体电路整合度
来实现尺寸非常精巧的无线电终端设备
同时还要保持非常低的功耗
因为用户终端设备对于价格空耗都非常的严格
并且要遵守最佳化的无线电成本要求
所谓的上传下载变频器 UDC
称为Updown Converter
这个是用户终端设备里面基础的射频机体电路
主要是将调变解调器里面的中频或基频资讯
直接连接到KU频段或者KA频段
射频机体电路RFIC里面的上传下载变频器
它的频率覆盖目标主要是KU频段
包括10到14GHz
下载的连线也就是卫星到地面
是7GHz到12GHz
上传的连线也就是从地面到卫星
是14GHz到5GHz
而KA频段的通讯频率是18GHz到31GHz
其中下载的连线也就是从卫星到地面
是7GHz到21GHz
而上传的连线也就是地面到卫星是27GHz到31GHz
因为下载的连线和上传的连线频率上是分开的
所以从卫星到用户终端的通讯会使用两个单独的频段
而射频机体电路必须针对不同的频段来设计用户终端设备的上传下载变频器
由于低伪到卫星是不断的快速移动
所以终端设备的上传下载变频器
它的频率合成器
必须能够实现快速的锁定
才能够提供不间断的连接
而频率合成器
用来辅助上传频率跟下载频率
让终端在运作期间
连接和重新连接不同卫星
就发挥非常重要的作用
因为从一颗卫星到另外一颗卫星
在空中频率发生变化的工作阶段
也就是KA跟KU频段
必须不断的变化
而亚德诺ADI开发了一系列
针对用户终端设备的KA和KU频段的上传下载变频器
来解决尺寸重量面积功耗和成本的问题
这里面包含射频和中频的讯号处理功能
譬如说滤波器放大器衰减器
所向回路和电压控制震荡器
以及功率检测等等
所有的射频机体电路RFIC设计
都有将用户终端讯号连线的性能纳入考量
这个图就是ADI的上传变频器
ADMV4630
左边是卫星通讯的调变解调器
输出的中频讯号
输入这一颗上传变频器
转换成射频输出到天线
其中输入的中频讯号是3到5GHz
而输出的射频讯号是14到14.5GHz
功耗只有1.7瓦
封装尺寸只有6×6毫米
这一个则是ADI的下载变频器
ADMV4640
射频讯号从右边输入
经由下载变频器转换成中频讯号输出
再经由卫星通讯的调变解调器进行处理
它的射频端输入频率是10.7到12.7GHz
中频的输出频率是1.4到2.5GHz
功耗只有1.35瓦
封装尺寸只有6×6毫米
下来我们跟大家谈谈更高性能的终端上传下载变频器
在终端市场有一些应用是由性能来驱动
对于尺寸和最低成本设计的目标限制就比较少
这些应用可以选用离散式的射频机体电路解决方案
由于元件是在不同的封装里面
因此就可以混合多种不同的制程技术
包括可以使用金属半导体厂效电晶体MES
或者高电子移动速度电晶体HEMT
或者双极性互补型的金属氧化物半导体
By CMOS
甚至是互补型的金属氧化物半导体
CMOS机体电路来最佳化设计需求
这个意思就是说呢
当你的终端装置限制比较少的时候
我们就可以用很多颗不同的射频
机体电路依照实际的需求
兜出客户想要的产品
这种离散式的设计允许对性能跟尺寸来进行权衡
所以设计的弹性就比较大
设计人员可以创建更高性能更高输出功率
并且支援更宽的平宽
而且设计人员可以提高接收的灵敏度来改善动态范围和砸散的性能
意思就是说
使用很多颗离散的射频机体电路整合出来的解决方案
会有更大的设计灵活度
也可以设计出更好的产品
当然体积就会变大
特别是地面站或杂道器也是属于这一类解决方案通常啊杂道器的尺寸比较大所以呢它的整合度要求跟终端装置就不一样意思就是说呢杂道器可以使用离扇型不同的射频基底电路来整合出产品
而且杂道器利用不同制程技术
就可以为市场提供最佳化的解决方案
所以这边就谈到呢
雅德诺ADI持续扩大这种离扇式解决方案的系列产品
来因应这个使用场景
大家现在看到下面的这个图呢
就是使用亚德诺ADI
很多颗不同的射频基底电路
所整合出来的产品
所以呢
这个图里面的HMC-788A和HMC-566
这个是功率放大器
HMC-798A这个是混平器
ADF-4372
这个是锁向回路和电压控制震荡器
而这一个LTC-5596是功率侦测器
用很多颗离散的射频机体电路
整合出来的产品体积变大
但是它的设计灵活度变高
可以针对特定的场景来进行设计
最后这个文章就谈到
传统需要专业的承包商来安装设备
和定位卫星的位置
因此它的安装成本就变高
所以很多家公司都想要努力消除这种安装成本
来降低用户终端的部署成本
为了实现这个目标
就必须将天线和处理通讯的连线
所需要的电子元件
比如一项的元件
射频机体电路
结合在一个室外单元当中
这个室外单元ODU
它是位于室外
并且瞄准天空里面的一种天线阵列
而室内单元通常是连接到室外单元
来进行有线或无线通讯的传统路由器
才能让终端用户的个人电脑
或者行动电话提供网际网路的连接
意思是室外单元是连接到天线和卫星通讯
而室内单元则是一个路由器连接到个人电脑或行动电话
提供终端装置上网
由于低轨道卫星会有许多卫星进出地面终端
所以使用电子可控天线这个称为ESA
就可以透过电子的方式控制卫星通讯的方向
来发射和接收电磁波
这个称为波速成型
实现很高的电磁波指向性
因此使用电子可控天线
它的效率会提高很多
所以当卫星进出用户终端的视野
从一颗卫星到另外一颗卫星切换
几乎是瞬间就完成
大家知道传统的卫星通讯是使用叠形天线
而叠形天线面对低轨道卫星高速移动的时候
要对准卫星非常困难
最后这个文章就谈到
传统需要专业的承包商来安装设备和定位卫星的位置
因此它的安装成本就变高
而使用电子可控天线
也就是相位阵列天线
利用很多天线发射的电磁波
形成建设性干涉和破坏性干涉
来控制电磁波的方向
这样就可以及时的对准低轨道卫星进行电磁波的切换
将卫星进出用户终端的视野
从一颗卫星到另外一颗卫星
它的切换几乎是瞬间完成
让整个通讯连线可以持续保持
而且考虑到轨道周期和正常运作的过程
需要连接卫星的数量很多
所以电子可控天线几乎是必不可少的要求
而电子可控天线又分成被动式的电子可控天线
也就是许多的天线
共用射频前端和传送接收器
还有主动式的电子可控天线
也就是每一个天线都有各自独立的传送接收器
连接到射频前端
为了要支援电子可控天线
雅德诺ADI就开发出KU频段的波速成型整合电路
这个称为BFIC
ADMV4680是针对用户终端设备所设计的细晶片解决方案
透过半双弓的通道独立控制讯号的增益和相位
而且这一个射频机体电路的尺寸只有8.2毫米平方
大家现在看到的这一个晶片是四个通道的波速成型整合电路
它的尺寸只有3.23×2.53毫米
里面有四个增益和相位调整单元
每一个都有独立的发射端功率放大器和接收端低杂讯放大器
可以同时连接四组天线
为人要开发波速成型整合电路的技术
来让无线通讯成本最小化
最重要的知识就是系统和正列天线相关的专业知识
包含机械组装还有印刷电路板的设计
包括堆叠和乘数
这个是无线通讯成本驱动的因素
在开发波速成型整合电路的时候
必须顾及机械和印刷电路板的设计
来降低整体的无线通讯成本
另外最高性能的终端应用
还是要使用双抛物面操作的天线
在这种情形下
成本跟美观就不是主要的因素
性能才是重点
对于消费性
注重成本的小型企业解决方案
使用电子可控天线
是实现低成本无线通讯
并且达成系统设计目标最有效的方式
这个低轨道卫星的网际网路
是一个新的领域
目前大多数的政府和网际网路
供应商都在参与这一场太空竞赛
随着全球连接网路的需求不断提高
低轨道卫星会进一步增强第三代合作伙伴计划的标准
从太空到农业地区都能够连接网路
这样才能在5G甚至未来的6G中发挥重要的作用
最后我们简单做一个结论
低轨道卫星里面最重要的射频机体电路
也就是上传下载变频器
为了要降低终端设备的成本
因此使用整合的射频机体电路
由于低轨道卫星的移动速度非常快
因此地面的接收设备
必须使用向位阵列天线
也就是电子可控天线
来控制电磁波的方向
才能够追踪卫星
保持卫星通讯的畅通
而低轨道卫星所使用的地面接收设备
里面射频机体电路非常重要的元件
就是上传下载电频器UDC
今天我们就简单的跟大家介绍这个元件的工作原理
大家有任何关于地轨道卫星或者地面接收设备的问题
欢迎大家发表在影片的下方
我们再来讨论
谢谢大家
晚安
拜拜
优优独播剧场——YoYo Television Series Exclusive